so there's a very sinister new character
that now is becoming a prominent player
in right-wing media and it is really
reminiscent of soviet-era propaganda not
only in substance but also
kind of in appearance and you'll you'll
see what i mean in a moment some
relatively short period of time ago
donald trump hired a new spokeswoman and
that spokeswoman is a woman named liz
harrington
and i'm going to play uh a couple of
clips of her from the media from the
last couple of days
and it is not only what comes out of her
mouth mouth that is sort of out and out
soviet style propaganda
even the appearance is weird where like
it's not clear if it's a green screen or
or what's going on but even like her
skin tone and the production value
is reminiscent of like cold war era
propaganda and or hostagevid type videos
um and
it's it's all very very crazy so let's
take a look at this first clip this is
from real america's voice the war room
with i guess steve bannon i don't know
let's take a look at this and um you
know this could be straight out of uh
of of the soviet era russia i want they
can try to raid as many donald j trump
supporters as they want we're just going
to keep coming we're going to keep
pressing forward we're gonna get the
truth about the election and everyone
will believe it everyone already knows
that this election was wrong that
something was not right it is 15 months
since the election she's talking about
15 months and much like
we we've seen in propaganda movements
elsewhere you know north korea insists
uh kim jong-il really
got a hole in one on every hole the
first time he played golf and controls
rainbows and all this different stuff
and nobody believes it but at the same
time everybody sort of pretends to
believe it and they keep repeating it
and you have to go along
similar to the things we hear out of
russia similar to things we've heard
from you know all sorts of different
places and the production value
uh is like a cross between
soviet propaganda videos and old 90s
video games i used to play like duke
nukem 3d i mean it's all just strange
but 15 months later folks they are
saying
the evidence is coming
any day now we're going to get the
evidence
uh here's another clip also again i
don't know if it's a poorly lit green
screen or what it is but the appear she
looks like she's being held hostage and
here's a longer propaganda clip
you know liz i think one of the reasons
a lot of our colleagues in the old media
don't want to talk about it is they know
he is going to be a force du jour in the
next election i recently saw a little
letter that uh governor younkin sent the
president thanking for his help in
getting elected in virginia that's
something that the mainstream media
doesn't want to talk about but tell us
about how donald trump is going to play
a role in the 22 uh 2022 election yeah
as kevin mccarthy and troops try to take
across the house and the senate
well the power of the endorsement that's
another thing that is ignored by the
fake news but it's not ignored in the
world of politics i can tell you
everyone wants the trump endorsement
they're always hounding us for that ever
important endorsement because they know
it will put them over the finish line so
now it's not really true that trump's
record is so good i mean in the 2018
midterms to go back to a midterm trump
endorsed 75 candidates and about half of
them won 55 percent won
it's not that good particularly when you
consider the power of incumbency and a
bias to success when you're endorsing
incumbents during trump's entire
presidency 2017-2021
ballotpedia tracked
305 trump endorsements and then when he
left office he made another 49
endorsement so that's 354 total
his record was
77 percent one and again there's a major
bias to success because he mostly was
endorsing incumbents and incumbents
usually win so
his record really isn't that good but it
doesn't matter they have now gone fully
in this you can't believe what anybody
tells you
you can't believe what you see you can't
believe what you hear you can't even
believe what you believe is to be
evidence even that you have to doubt you
have to believe
what liz harrington tells you
from her bizarre
bizarrely lit extremely weird screen
that that she's coming to you from
and this is likely going to continue
and if and until you know yesterday we
talked about the whole rogan thing
rogan's saying people aren't smart if
they listen to me for vaccine advice and
much the same way the people that are
watching this stuff are people who don't
have the critical thinking skills they
don't have the media literacy
wherewithal to question the messages and
the things that they are being told and
so in all likelihood they're going to
continue believing it and
the impacts of that are certainly going
to be felt in the midterms
one of our sponsors is cometier coffee
cometier coffee is delicious i can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their brewing process captures
over 2 000 flavor compounds then the
coffee is flash frozen locking in the
flavor it arrives at your home frozen in
a fully recyclable capsule all you have
to do is melt it by adding hot water or
cold water for iced coffee it takes
seconds it's the most convenient way
that i have ever made coffee i've been
impressed with how the process protects
the flavor i really enjoy cometier they
have a variety of flavor options light
medium and dark single origin and
blended coffee roasts from the best
specialty roasters you'll get twenty
dollars off when you go to cometeer.com
pacman the link is underneath this video